alors cet âge want a fait mais surtout
ta complice de vie ensemble nous avons
toujours réussi à faire face à tous les
défis
ce message d'amour pour sa mère johanne
sauvette et leur était loin de se douter
que ce serait le dernier elle avait
ouvrir les yeux quand l'entente ma voie
absence de communication erreur sur la
personne
la famille du guide blondeur a vécu un
horrible fiasco depuis deux semaines
jusqu'à vendredi dernier
on appelait aux heures 11h30 puis après
6h 6h15 à peu près en a reçu un appel de
la résidence pour nous dire que ma maman
était décédée à césar
cet ancien politicienne et décider de
lakovic 19 au ch et celle des arènes à
l'âge de 80 ans on n'a pas eu le
résultat du test du tout un décès
difficile à encaisser pour son beau fils
et on n'en n'ont plus jamais été informé
que le siège avait pris contrôle avait
été la résidence était sous tutelle
privé de visite à sa mère depuis des
semaines johan sauvette et leur c'est
donc raccrocher depuis son décès à cette
courte vidéo vais voir quelle était pas
même physiquement en santé qu'elle était
propre puisqu'elle était souriante ce ça
fait beaucoup de bien
la perte de sa mère dans c'est désolant
circonstances n'est qu'une étape dans
son processus de deuil
si on veut mettre une plaque
personnalisée
un deuil qu'elle risque de ne pas vivre
pleinement puisqu'il n'y aura pas de
funérailles traditionnelles à cause du
virus
je vous dirais que le côté plus
difficile c'est de pas pouvoir prendre
nos enfants nous sommes en deuil dans
notre bloc car en pleine crise du
coronavirus les indications du coroner
en chef du québec sont claires pour les
défunts quand quelqu'un décède et qui
est porteur du koweit 19
on nous demande que la personne soit
incinéré immédiatement suite au décès la
crémation est donc presque automatique
sauf exception
ça pourrait contrevenir à certaines
croyances de certaines personnes
il serait possible de pouvoir inhumer le
corps de quelqu'un si les délais sont
raisonnables mais il ne faut qu'ils
aient aucune pratique qui a été fait sur
l'accord qui nous ont manqué
l'atmosphère absence de cérémonie report
des funérailles aux calendes grecques
l'impact psychologique n'est pas à
négliger il faut essayer de reproduire
au travail se rapprochant de la personne
disparue de toutes sortes de façons
alors comme je vous dis pour certains
signes revisiter des photos pour
d'autres c'est de revisiter des
souvenirs c'est d'en parler en famille
le processus de deuil il peut pas se
mettre sur la glace suis à l'arrêt foule
vivre qu'elle a eu les deux n'ont qu'un
don d'organes pour ses beaux yeux bleus
johan et andré compte bien rendre un
hommage spécial à la disparue après la
crise
laissés à eux mêmes comme bien d'autres
familles face au processus de
funérailles manquer ils ont un conseil
pour les prochains point de presse du
gouvernement le beau au lieu de dire
simplement mes condoléances
c'est de prendre deux minutes pour dire
vous savez si vous avez deux minutes je
veux simplement vous expliquer qu est ce
qui va se passer et leur message est
clair pour les personnes qui vont vivre
ce qu'ils ont vécu
soyez prêt parce que quand la nouvelle
arrive puis on et émotivement bouleversé
on n'a pas le goût tu commences à passer
à travers la tonne de papier qu'on doit
remplir et pourtant l'exemple de
battants consolation face à cette
douloureuse perte
johan aura au moins pu faire entendre ce
dernier message à sa maman parti pour
toujours aux plus beaux sort et qui a su
charmer tous ceux et celles qui ont eu
le privilège de te connaître je t'aime
hommes